ich habe mich heute auf gericht über
tillmann kuban den vorsitzenden der
jungen union warum er hat in einem
interview gesprochen über die erneuerung
der cdu konkret über die neubesetzung
des parteivorsitzes der ist ja wichtig
geworden weil armin laschet ja irgendwie
erklärt hat irgendwann mal davon
zurückzutreten und seine große hoffnung
sagte kuban ist dass sich auch eine frau
bewirkt denn so erwarte ich finde frauen
sagen sie wollen mehr einfluss dann
sollen auch frauen kandidieren
das ist ein echtes laut berger sei ja
ich bin eine doppelspitze fähige frauen
gibt es in der cdu viele das weiß auch
kuban und einer der fähigsten für diesen
parteivorsitz ist silvia brea die ist
jetzt schon stellvertretende
cdu-vorsitzende wir sehen hier ja diesen
lustigen punker schnitt sie kommt aus
niedersachsen konkret aus der region
cloppenburg dafür die cds die cdu/csu
ergebnisse ein nämlich immer absolute
mehrheit und ja aber nicht an er jedes
mal silvia bauer ist 8 manche sagen das
anders reguliert 48 jahre jünger drei
kindern diese halbe punkfrisur sie wäre
für viele auch genau richtig hier die
cdu in eine neue phase zu führen eine
mischung aus modernen familienorientiert
konservativ uns das so ja nur sie will
nicht denn sagt sie selbst ich habe drei
kinder
weil ihre kinder so sagt sie mindestens
ein recht offenbar macht haben und sie
sagt auch das ist das problem der cdu
und es darf doch nicht sein dass es
innerhalb der cdu innerhalb dieser
partei ich mich entscheiden muss ob ich
jetzt karriere machen oder kinder kriege
das sagt die stellvertretende
cdu-vorsitzende und ich habe mich
gefragt was denn da los 16 jahre wurde
dieser partei geführt von zwei frauen 15
jahre von angela merkel oder 14 und dann
eben von angela von frau kramp
karrenbauer und anni es nicht
hinbekommen die sinnvolle arbeitsteilung
zu schaffen zwischen kindern und
karriere stattdessen werden jetzt wieder
die fähigsten frauen das sehe ich so uni
an den rand gedrängt in dem sie die
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf in
frage stellen und unmöglich macht und
dann hier in dieses versagen noch mit
kecken sprüchen wie im fall von herrn
kuban ich finde das darf nicht sein
weder in der cdu und auch in diesem land
also ich meine zweifel eine bemerkung
zurück indem ich sage die männer sind
auch nicht besser ich sehe das ganz
anders ehrlich gesagt einem tisch und
ich dafür sozusagen
denn sonst wäre es wahrscheinlich
aufmerksam ich finde ich finde wirklich
schwierig ist immer also man will einen
spitzen job das ist ja wirklich wir
reden jetzt nicht über meine
abgeordneter da können wir gerne darüber
reden wie man karriere und familie
verbinden aber entweder den top job das
ist ja wie im unternehmen ich finde wenn
ich jetzt sagen würde ich möchte
vorstandschefin werden irgendwo
irgendwann er kann ich nicht davon
ausgehen dass dann wäre das die firma
dann sagt frau schenkt er super toll sie
kriegen einen acht stunden job also sie
müssen nur acht stunden am tag hier sein
der manager ist alles da muss ich es
privat die lösung finde das heißt er
muss ich mir eigentlich ein mann suchen
er sagt ich bleibe zu hause macht
karriere ich verstehe nicht warum man
mir die privaten probleme unternehmen
oder parteien suchen erlösen müssen das
ist für mich in diesen positionen das
ist die top job top position ist es für
mich nicht verständlich warum und da
muss ich immer an kuba oder auch andere
will ich in schutz nehmen wenn man den
topjob will und die top-position so eine
position ist einfach ist übrigens bei
männern auch nicht dass man dann das
extrakt immer alles planen kann mit
familie und jeden abend seinen kinder
ins bett bringen kann das heißt da finde
ich warum machen wir immer private
probleme zu problemen der wirtschaft
oder ja sogar auch zu der der politik
das macht sie sagte nur ich will den
sonntag oder so beispielsweise mit den
kindern verbringen und will nicht dann
sonntagmorgen los und dann irgendwas
machen und dafür muss es lösungen geben
oder wir kennen das doch auch von
politikern männern die da ewig
zusammensetzen und irgendwas bereden was
schon links geklärt sein könnte wenn man
die effizienz von frauen an den tag legt
also ich bin ja nicht feministin als
mann oder so aber ich finde dass die
frauen in solchen punkten sicherlich
auch eine richtige haltung habe und dass
man mehr tun kann um frauen ist zu
ermöglichen kinder und karriere zusammen
zu bringen gerade wenn man von einer
frau 16 jahre lang geführt ein für alle
mal auf den anderen funktionäre aus
silvia brea ich meine dass der name er
hat also den candy kennen niemand in
deutschland vielleicht eine quote stimmt
dass wir über silvia breher reden als
jemand der jetzt irgendwie wahnsinnig
wichtig in der cdu sein könnte zeigt die
ganze katastrophe dieser union ich meine
entschuldigung waren das ist kann nicht
wahr sein dass irgendwie sind wir bremer
jetzt irgendwie eine wichtige funktion
und
natürlich ist sie das aber sie ist dass
diese daran gestolpert am ende und die
haben keinen in der ersten reihe da
irgendwie das ding übernehmen kann
klassisch also und auch nicht in der
zweiten reihe wieder suchen von dem
personal zukunft
musizieren eine echte chance also ich
will ja keine ratschläge von der von der
seitenlinie geben weil jeder hat mal die
erfahrung gemacht im politischen was das
bedeutet wenn das scheinwerferlicht sich
woanders hin richtet wenn es ausgeht
aber das tor die riesenchance sich neu
zu sortieren sich neu aufzustellen und
mit wem und auch mit denen fragen
auseinander
natürlich kann eine politikern haben
sonst am sonntagvormittag sagen ich
nehme keine termine an für
sonntagvormittag oder ganzen sonntag
könnte sie das problem ist ja nur immer
wieder wir haben das ja gesehen die
werden ja süchtig nach den terminen weil
dann wenn ein dienstwagen hingefahren
gucken sie schon 25 erwartungsvolle
augen an 26 und es knapp zu sagen ja
nun wird er in eine stadthalle geleitet
applaus applaus und hält eine
mittelprächtige rede davon leben doch
das ist doch es gibt adrenalin das gibt
selbstzufriedenheit aber dann zusätzlich
hätte jeder selbst oder jede selbst in
der hand zu sagen sonntags mache ich so
was nicht da machts mein stellvertreter
oder herr oder frau xy die keine kinder
haben könnte man sagen das macht man
aber nicht dass sie auch alle auf einmal
geht das nicht
doch noch glaubt dass ein
erwartungsmanagement ist grau und
diejenigen die am ende mit der termine
können weil der union setzen gefallen
tun wir sagen können jetzt mal jemanden
jeder der einen namen sagen dann gehen
wir mal einen ratschlag an die union
jeder wär's machen können frauen vom
südsudan jeder wie geben wir einen
ratschlag an die union herscheid sie
dürfen anfang der uni und ein einziger
name geben sie mal als veranschlagt wie
man sich nur aufbauen angefangen mit
betriebskindergärten an um vor allem
eine person die parteivorsitz machen
könnte für die union die sogenannte
geradesteht mich hier an sollen die
machen ja entspannt weil er den
unbedingten willen hat das ist aber
keine frau einige zeit
in der man definitiv sagen ich bin ob er
hier einsparen ist der einzige der für
neuanfang steht am ende wird es
natürlich auch nicht leicht für ihn der
hat immer noch sozusagen die korona
probleme an sich kleben hat auch die
ganzen anderen geschichten die die es
dort gab aber es am ende von den allen
der wahrscheinlichste wenn man länger
man dazu nehmen sie uns glaube ich vier
die im moment gehandelt werden von denen
keiner von denen ist
auch nur mittelfristige lösung
allerdings diese kurzfristige ich glaube
dass die wir müssen dann nach da müsste
sich aber ein bisschen stärker
profilieren und es nach kiel gucken was
wird aus günter dort der dort
ministerpräsident ist noch ziemlich
junger typ der hat sich als der
wahlkampf schief gelaufen ist gar nicht
mehr geäußert hat sich in die büsche
geschlagen und hat jetzt schon mal
gesagt er will nicht vorsitzender werden
jetzt würde es auch gar nicht aber wenn
er jetzt ein bisschen anfängt sich
bundespolitische positionieren könnte
das vielleicht in vier fünf jahren
werden und das sollte er werden und
jetzt so
kurzfristig lieber himmel auch ihr habt
ja ganz nett für den tollen
fraktionsvorsitzenden vergessen daniel
günther der manchen linken koalieren
wollte da zumindest das irgendwie
irgendwann endet auch mal so ja
ich sehe ehrlich gesagt aber das ist mir
bei den kanzlerkandidaten ganz genau so
gegangen wenn ich gefragt werde wer sind
überzeugender vorsitzender ist keiner
und das habe ich bei den
kanzlerkandidaten auch gesagt wer ist
ein überzeugender kanzler keiner und
jetzt haben wir einen normalen so kann
was für die cdu ja deswegen sehen wir
berichten
problem ist alt sein da ist niemand
von den kandidaten könnt euch eine
sparen ist für mich nicht also da wir
haben im parteivorsitz kanzlerkandidaten
könnte ich auch super werden
will ein verein aus wenn du kannst
sicher
bringt wissen wollt dann sage ich günter
in kiel
argumentiert zwar ganz vorn ein also ich
glaube dahinter ich meine entschuldigung
war dass er ist derjenige der den ball
hans hass und über die amerikanische
oder links koalition sich eigentlich
keiner mehr von friedrich merz naja also
zum dritten mal da wird natürlich bei
der basis in zum basis befragungen gibt
wieder antreten käme es war glück für
die fdp dass er nicht angetreten ist
weil ich glaube dass rücken er hat nicht
ganz so ausgeprägt aber auch charakter
probleme sowieso da aber eher werden
gute oppositionsführern aber ich denke
jemand der variante politik märz im
bundestag ich weiß nicht ob er sich
beliebt macht dort aber er war jemand
der draufhauen reihe soll die leber
gleichen hinterfragt und diese optionen
aussehen aber trotzdem bleibt wenn du
zweimal verloren hat dann wieder
anzutreten und dritten mal irgendwie ich
meine der hat ja nun wirklich also
dachte er wird jetzt endlich minister
wollte schon habt ihr parteitag
unbedingt minister werden und dann
dachte jetzt das wird ja schon irgendwie
wirtschaftsminister werden wieder nichts
gewonnen und jetzt noch mal so sagen na
ja vielleicht für die basisbefragung
kommt trete ich dann doch noch mal an
das ist ja alles grauen habe ich meine
entschuldigung das ist ja willy brandt
ist auch viermal angetreten bevor wir
dann endlich ich glaube schon dass wir
jetzt wirklich das leben
wir können aber wir wollen auch keinen
abschließenden geben
[Musik]